[Música]
el expresidente de Estados Unidos Donald
Trump abusó sexualmente a la escritora y
giancarroll y posteriormente la difamó
una corte de Manhattan lo sentenció por
estos dos delitos y añadió que la
denunciante no provoque hubiera
violación como tal
sin acuerdo así culminó la reunión entre
el presidente baidén y los líderes del
congreso para aumentar el techo de la
deuda de Estados Unidos los republicanos
de la cámara condicionan el aumento en
el límite de endeudamiento a drástico
recortes al gasto público el mandatario
exige retirar de las negociaciones la
posibilidad de caer en impagos
y la asamblea nacional de Ecuador aprobó
continuar con el juicio político contra
el presidente Guillermo lasso el
mandatario enfrentará el proceso por
presunta malversación según la acusación
lazo habría permitido la firma de un
contrato lesivo para el estado ampliamos
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un placer
estar con ustedes abrimos en Estados
Unidos en donde la corte Federal de
Manhattan encontró responsable al
expresidente de Estados Unidos Donald
Trump para usar sexualmente y difamar a
la escritora a Jean Carlos después de
una serie de audiencias legales en las
que Trump no estuvo presente Carla alegó
que Trump la violó entre 1995 y 1996 sin
embargo la corte descartó este argumento
Aunque sí le imputó los otros dos
crímenes
Donald Trump responsable de abuso sexual
y difamación este fue El veredicto del
Jurado en la corte Federal de Manhattan
sobre el juicio iniciado por la
escritora y Jim Carroll que acusa al
expresidente de violarla en una tienda
departamental en Nueva York que en los
90s al ser un juicio civil la libertad
de Trump no estaba en juego pero la
corte le concedió a la escritora una
indemnización por 5 millones de dólares
por daños y prejuicios el alegato de
violación fue rechazado por la corte sin
embargo el equipo legal de Trump expresó
que están listos para apelar la decisión
fue un veredicto extraño esta fue una
demanda por violación fue un caso de
violación todo el tiempo y el Jurado
rechazó eso pero hizo otras conclusiones
Así que obviamente apelaremos esas otras
conclusiones
no se presentó a las audiencias del
juicio y a través de su perfil en la red
social de la cual es dueño rechazó la
decisión Del Jurado
No tengo idea de quién es esta mujer
este veredicto es una desgracia Es la
continuación de la cacería de brujas más
grande de la historia la escritora
dedicó su Victoria a todas aquellas que
han sufrido porque no les creyeron a
pesar del veredicto y de enfrentar otras
causas legales Donald Trump se mantiene
como líder en las encuestas para
convertirse en el nominado del partido
de republicano lo que le permitiría
aspirar nuevamente a la presidencia en
2024 también en Estados Unidos el
presidente Joe biden se reunió con el
presidente de la cámara baja Kevin
mccarthy y los otros tres líderes del
congreso para discutir el aumento del
techo de la deuda las conversaciones
Fueron calificadas por el presidente
como productivas sin embargo no se llegó
a ningún acuerdo para solucionar el
problema de liquidez del gobierno el
primero de junio es el día en donde si
no se eleva el límite de la deuda el
gobierno podría quedarse sin dinero para
pagar sus cuentas el informe por Max
Pérez Gallardo el aumento del de deuda
sigue atascado tras un esperado
encuentro en la oficina oval Este martes
el presidente estadounidense Joe biden
no consiguió desencallar las
negociaciones para que el congreso
apruebe la elevación del límite de deuda
que el gobierno pueda adquirir para
saldar sus cuentas el ala republicana
mantiene una posición Clara no se
elevará el techo de deuda si no hay
recortes en el gasto público
todos en esta reunión reiteraron las
posiciones en las que están no hay
ningún movimiento nuevo el presidente
dijo que el personal debería volver a
reunirse pero fui muy claro con el
presidente Ahora solo nos quedan dos
semanas en una conferencia de prensa
posterior a la reunión biden descartó la
posibilidad de que Estados Unidos no
cumpla con sus obligaciones financieras
y no descarta invocar la décimo cuarta
enmienda de la Constitución dicha
enmienda en su sección cuarta le
permitiría al presidente Elevar el techo
de deuda unilateralmente sin embargo
este es un proceso largo que tiene que
ser revisado por el poder judicial hoy
el gobierno trabaja contrarreloj Bueno
he estado considerando la decimocuarta
enmienda y un hombre por el que siente
una enorme respeto Larry que me asesoró
durante mucho tiempo cree que sería
legítimo pero el problema es que tendría
que ser litigado y mientras tanto sin
una extensión todavía terminaría en el
mismo lugar
la secretaria del tesoro ha advertido
que el gobierno podría quedarse sin
fondos para el primero de junio una
eventualidad que llevaría la primera
potencia mundial a caer en un impago por
primera vez en su historia con
consecuencias no sólo internas sino
globales
pero esta crisis de deuda no es la única
que afronta la administración biden
autoridades estadounidenses albergues
Iglesias y organizaciones humanitarias
se preparan para la llegada masiva de
migrantes a la frontera con México con
el final del título 42 este próximo 11
de mayo una medida que permitía la
expulsión inmediata de solicitantes de
asilo en ese país argumentando motivos
de salud pública
para estos migrantes los días previos al
fin del título 42 se dividen entre la
incertidumbre y la esperanza
cientos de ellos permanecen varados en
la frontera entre Estados Unidos y
México esperan que el fin de la polémica
a medida les permita cruzar hacia la
Unión Americana pero la situación podría
salirse de control según las autoridades
va a ser caótico durante un tiempo y
como planteé en la reunión Cuando
hablaron de recortes de no gastar dinero
qué demonios pasa si recortas vas a
recortar agentes en la frontera
necesitamos más en la frontera no menos
en la frontera
biden y su homólogo mexicano Andrés
Manuel López Obrador hablaron Este
martes acordaron que ambos gobiernos
colaborarán en materia migratoria
las ciudades fronterizas ya están en
alerta la situación Aquí como ustedes
ven de más de mil personas fuera de la
parroquia y todos los albergues ya
llenos a reventar pues una situación una
crisis humanitaria cierto no solo crisis
migratoria sino crisis humanitaria donde
vemos que muchos de nuestros hermanos y
hermanas migrantes Pues están quedando
en la calle durmiendo la intemperie con
una sola comida al día Muchas veces y
dentro de Estados Unidos la situación
lleva incluso a urbes lejanas a tomar
medidas
hemos visto en las últimas dos semanas
un nuevo aumento de migrantes que llegan
a diario por eso hoy emitimos una
declaración de emergencia para responder
a la llegada de migrantes
las autoridades estadounidenses se
preparan para una llegada de hasta
10.000 migrantes por día la frontera sin
embargo Washington ha anunciado medidas
como el despliegue de militares para
contener la crisis
en Nicaragua la Corte Suprema de
Justicia controlada por el oficialismo
suspendió de forma definitiva a la
abogada John Arqui Martínez una
reconocida defensora de los presos
políticos de ese país la justicia
nicaragüense declaró nulo el título de
abogado y notario público de la
defensora y le solicitaron entregar sus
protocolos organismos de Derechos
Humanos denunciaron que la acción es una
nueva modalidad represiva contra los
disidentes Martínez quien ha sobrevivido
a atentados y amenazas de muerte en los
últimos días había denunciado y
documentado varias redadas policiales en
contra de opositores al gobierno de
Daniel Ortega
y vamos a Ecuador porque con 88 votos la
asamblea nacional aprobó continuar el
juicio político contra el presidente
Guillermo lasso El mandatario es acusado
del delito de peculado y ahora el órgano
legislativo deberá convocar a una nueva
sesión para enjuiciar y votar su
destitución Gustavo Ortega corresponsal
de France 24 en Quito nos amplió los
detalles la asamblea nacional resolvió
en juicial al presidente de la república
Guillermo lasso para seguir con el
proceso se necesitaba una votación de
mayoría simple esto es la mitad más uno
de los asambleístas presentes en la sala
el pleno alcanzó los votos y
posteriormente aprobó el llamado a
juicio político la acusación inicial
fueron supuesto delito de peculado las
acusaciones están relacionadas con la
firma de un contrato de la flota
petrolera ecuatoriana flopper para el
transporte de petróleo que causaron el
perjuicio del estado por supuesto
conocimiento al presidente según los
asambleístas la convocatoria tuvo lugar
luego de que no se alcanzaron los votos
en la comisión de fiscalización a favor
de un informe no vinculante que no
recomendaba el juicio al mandatario el
presidente del parlamento anunció que al
no haber un texto aprobado no existe un
informe y lo desarrollado no tenía
efecto jurídicos una vez reunidos los
votos la asamblea nacional deberá
continuar con el juicio político al
presidente de la república se deben
cumplir con plazos de ley para convocar
a la sesión y llamar así la votación
según los tiempos legales la sesión se
podría realizar entre el 14 y el 16 de
mayo la empresa aeronáutica brasileña
hembraer y la sueca saab han abierto
Este martes una nueva línea de
producción de aviones de combate en
Brasil se trata del modelo gripe del
cual Brasil tiene un contrato para la
compra de 36 aeronaves según dicho
acuerdo 15 de ellas se producirán en la
nueva fábrica en el estado de Sao Paulo
desde sapa aseguran que esperan que
Brasil se convierta en su exportador de
estos aviones en América Latina
con esta noticia Cerramos el informativo
sigan conectados a France 24 y France
24.com
[Música]